I just moved to LA I knew I wanted to be
an actor my friend said you what you
need is a head shot I was at the post
office a predominantly gay area there's
a guy looking at me for a long
time and he was like do you model I'm a
photographer do you model and I was like
no but I need uh have you ever heard of
head shots do you do head shot he's like
yeah my apartment is two blocks from
here I was like well what does it cost
he's like I'll cover you I was like oh
let's go so I walk over to the apartment
he was like listen probably need a
shower I was like that's a really good
idea and then he was like that shirt's
not going to do here's one of mine he
takes a bunch of photos and he's like
directing me telling me what to do takes
the film out of the camera and he was
like good luck kid and I just walked out
yeah that stick to that story as
well he's probably making money of those
pictures he took of you in the shower
that you know about